MARK MIRCHANDANI: We're excited
to share a preview of version
4 of the Job Search API.
This is just a beta
preview, so everything
is subject to change.
That being said, there's
some cool stuff coming up,
so let's dive into it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Our previous code samples
were all using version 3,
so they'll still work if you
want to start from there.
As always, the
documentation has all
of the up-to-date information
on which versions are available
and how to use them.
Version 4 is currently
in beta and has
some cool new advantages
that you can use.
First up-- there's now the
ability to use tenants.
Tenants are entities that let
you group companies and jobs,
instead of having everything
grouped under your GCP project.
This way, you can
easily isolate tenants
without having to create new
GCP projects, especially useful
for things like hiring
agency and job sites working
with multiple organizations.
By default, you'll have a tenant
ID when you set up a Job Search
API.
So if you don't want
to worry about tenants,
you don't have to.
You can continue to use the API
in the same way as version 3,
and it'll always assume
the default tenant.
You can also create a
new tenant with the API,
then use that for everything
by explicitly specifying it.
You can create as
many tenants as you
need to organize your
companies and jobs.
If you're just looking for
your default tenant ID,
just create a company
without specifying a tenant,
and you'll be able to
find the ID in the newly
created company's name.
Besides tenants, there's
also some new features
around the commute search.
The Job Search API
lets you search
by a user's preferred
commute time
by driving and public transport.
Version 4 adds walking
and biking to this search,
so you can give your users
an even better experience
when just looking for jobs.
Just include a
commute filter object
when making a search request
to filter the results
by the commute parameter.
There's more specifics
in the documentation.
Just as important as the
user search experience
is your experience
implementing the API.
That's why the
event handling API
has been created to help make
the client event system easier
to integrate.
This is the part
of the API where
you pass in events from users
interacting with the search,
so the machine-learning
models can be fine-tuned.
For example, when a user clicks
on a job to see more details,
you can pass along
a VIEW message.
Once you hook up
the events API, you
can use the event's live
stream tool in the GCP console
to make sure that you see
the events as they come in.
In addition, the data
logging terms and conditions
have been updated, so you can
read exactly how the event
data is being used.
There's also a new API to create
or update jobs in batches,
and the client libraries
now support GRPC.
This should make it
easier and give you
more ways to integrate
the Job Search API.
Since this is all
currently in beta,
there's still changes coming.
Make sure to check the
documentation for the latest,
and please share your feedback.
Thanks for watching.
And remember, when
looking for talent,
it's OK to keep your
head in the Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]